what up how are you and welcome to
Auggie's Alamo City barbecue and what
we're doing today I'm with two cool cats
and we are talking barbecue and we are
talking the final four do you remember
this feeling like days before the final
four you know how to catch do when we're
in Texas so it's gonna add San Antonio
to the list when it comes to barbecue
what are you going what kind of ribs are
we doing I'm gonna go for it yeah
welcome my fork
I don't do this line oh hey me which one
has better flavor bait he didn't even
say that like they had more he was not
convinced no no all right we're gonna
find out here we go now they both
although they came from dinosaurs
that's a leak I don't know that looks
pretty humble Eagles can we can we get
this man a coke life please
the secret to hitting a game-winning
shot see you spent years practicing that
play you knew what was gonna happen like
Randy Moss a stray cash all right cash
only so what's the verdict on these ribs
I think I want I'm gonna start off with
the beat and then we're gonna go to pork
I just cooked so well alright so let's
try this one the cops move that would
well you lose there must be real enough
beef pork coca-cola it goes with either
of these cheers to a championship for
the cats
okay